l'hebdo politique bonsoir et bienvenue
dans l'hebdo politique votre rendez vous
du dimanche soir sur radio sensations en
association avec tv 78 épisodes 210 mon
invité ce soir et le candidat upr à
l'élection présidentielle françois
asselineau
[Musique]
les politiques
françois asselineau bonsoir bonsoir et
merci de me recevoir vous êtes le
président de l'union populaire
républicaine upr mouvements que vous
avez fondé en 2007 et pour lequel vous
avez toujours été président vous avez
commencé par être inspecteur des
finances avant de devenir haut
fonctionnaire dans plusieurs cabinets
ministériels
avant d'être élu en 2001 conseiller de
paris sur la liste de jean tiberi poste
que vous occuperez jusqu'en 2008 après
avoir tenté de vous présenter une
première fois à l'élection
présidentielle en 2012 vous y est
finalement parvenu en 2017 vous avez
terminé 9e sur onze candidats lors du
premier tour réunissant 332 1547 voix
soit 0 92% vous êtes lancer à nouveau
dans la campagne pour 2022 qu'est ce qui
vous fait croire que cette année peut
être la bonne pour vous et pour lui br
alors d'une part je pense que je vais
faire un score meilleur que la première
fois et d'autre part je m'en suis pas
tout à fait certain parce que nous
sommes entre avait alors pourquoi je
pense que je devrais faire un score
meilleur parce que les événements
survenus depuis cinq ans n'ont pas
arrêté de donner du crédit à tout mes
analyses on a d'ailleurs des vidéos on
va les sortir au cours des semaines qui
viennent de rappel de ce que j'ai pu
dire il y a cinq ans et de la réalité de
ce qui s'est produit c'est à dire qu'en
fait les gens qui ont voté macron ont
cru qu'il allait tout changer et c'est
en fait il a aggravé la situation
de la même façon que si madame pécresse
paris par exemple était élu puisse
coller le narratif qui est en train de
se mettre en place c'est que madame
pécresse serait la challenger de
monsieur macron 1 tout est en train
d'être organisées par les médias et les
instituts de sondage les grands médias
j'entends dans cette de cette façon si
d'aventuré d'un pékin succéder à
monsieur macron les français se rendrait
compte août six mois qu'elle fait
exactement la même politique donc moi
j'ai expliqué pourquoi j'ai expliqué que
tout est décidé par l'union européenne
par commission de bruxelles en vertu des
traités européens par la banque centrale
européenne à francfort pour tout ce qui
concerne l'euro la politique budgétaire
et contraintes monétaires etc et par
washington pour ce qui concerne l'otan
alors ça c'est les éléments qui
devraient normalement à faire que la
lame à notoriété a beaucoup progressé
une souris réseaux sociaux sur notre
site huppert point fr
nous faisons des scores considérable
jusqu'à deux millions deux millions cinq
cent mille 2 million deux cent mille vu
tout ça sont des éléments très positifs
les éléments négatifs c'est que tout est
organisé actuellement par les médias
pour organiser ce qu'on appelle les
journalistes comme l'invisibilité
c'est à dire que nous avons demandé des
dizaines de fois tous les grands médias
français de m'inviter je ne me suis
jamais ce qui est un véritable scandale
démocratique puisque aux élections
européennes qui ont suivi donc les
élections présidentielles celle d'il ya
deux ans en 2019 la liste que je menais
faisait 1,2 pour cent ans la virgule 2%
c'est pas énorme mais c'est quand même
pas 0 et nous avons calculé que sur les
douze grands médias du csa nous devrions
avoir donc 1,2 pour cent facile c'était
un proportionnelle ce serait assez
logique
1,2 pour cent des émissions politiques
sur douze grands médias y en a une par
jour ouvré à peu près on a fait le
calcul
au cours des deux années qui viennent de
s'écouler donc depuis les élections
européennes je réduis être invité
environ 75 x 75 x jeanne trans-al et 30
36 37 fois par an j'ai été invité 0 fois
au même moment vous avez des
personnalités je pense tout spécialement
à monsieur zemmour mais c'était le cas
en 2016 avec monsieur mâcon des
personnes qui ne se sont jamais
présentés à quelques rues élections que
ce soit qui donc comme bilan 11-0
électeurs et qui bénéficie d'une
promotion médiatique absolument
ahurissante donc ça veut dire que
l'élection présidentielle est en fait
phagocyter cannibalisé par quelques
grands médias donc par les propriétaires
de ces médias pour votre campagne vous
avez lancé une collecte de dons pour
atteindre 3 millions d'euros une
proposition est d'ailleurs revenu dans
le débat ces derniers des dernières
semaines seriez vous favorable à l'idée
que l'état créé une banque de la
démocratie pour que chaque candidat
puisse avoir accès à des financements
bancaires pour pour la campagne non mais
je pense que si vous voulez la mount le
mouvement politique que j'ai créé il a
une particularité c'est qu'il a zéro
euro d'endettement c'est un principe et
nous ne vivons que de l'argent que
veulent bien nous donner les français
sous forme de dons ou sous forme
d'adhésion de cotisation annuelle voilà
on a un tout petit plus sûr plus qui est
la vente de produits de la boutique
huppert dans le cadre de la de la loi
voilà c'est tout ce que nous faisons et
moi j'estime au contraire je trouve par
exemple que les partis politiques ne
devrait pas être financé par l'état si
un parti politique dit des choses qui
correspondent à ce que souhaitent les
français mais il trouvera l'argent si en
revanche il bénéficie d'un fonds de
commerce il ya des partis politiques je
pense pas que vous savez moi je le paye
je parle je parle cash un joli par
exemple que lui dit lui dit c'est une
coquille vide est-ce que vous avez déjà
vu autour de vous des gens qui sont
adhérents à lui dit non ils ont j'ai pas
2000 adhérents peut-être même pas
blessants ils ont des mini frison des
députés etc pourquoi parce qu'ils ont un
fond de commerce et donc ils passent
dans les médias il comme ils ont des
députés des sénateurs etc ils reçoivent
de l'argent public nous nous n'avons ni
député ni sénateur
nous n'avons rien mais en quoi lui dit
correspondait à ce que à ce que
souhaitent les français s'il y avait le
système que je dis nous devrions avoir
des partis politiques devraient tout
simplement
rechercher l'argent par eux mêmes
d'ailleurs nous quand vous citez les 3
millions d'euros
les trois millions d'euros que nous
sommes que nous ambitionnons de
collecter on en a déjà collecté
maintenant 190 euros à peu près c'est
pour l'élection présidentielle et les
élections législatives qui suivront et
puis si on à paris ve pas avoir tout
seul on réduira la voilure en 2017 nous
avons dépensé pour l'élection
présidentielle quelque chose comme un
million trois cent mille euros alors
même que certains dits paraît-il grands
candidats ont dépensé 22 millions
d'euros alors moi je ne sais pas comment
ils font pour dépenser cet argent
puisque ils ont ils n'ont pas fait des
choses extraordinaires
j'ai quand même vous donner quelque
chose à réfléchir nous on avait fait une
réunion publique porte de la villette
avec donc il ya vu 7000 personnes qui
étaient venues à paris c'était pour les
10 ans de l'upper quelques semaines
avant l'élection de la même façon que
nous allons faire la même chose pour les
15 ans le ca sera le samedi 26 mars 2000
2022 et bien pour organiser cette
réunion gigantesque on avait quand même
sept mille personnes s'étaient problème
beaucoup les médias de lyon n'ont
quasiment pas parlé ça nous avait coûté
180 mille euros
parce qu'il faut payer les locaux faut
payer les sièges sous payés
l'organisation générale la sécurité
les enceintes les éclairages et ses 180
me or je crois savoir que monsieur
sarkozy pour faire à peu près la même
chose dans la même paire même endroit
avait dépensé alors un peu plus y avait
peut-être du 10000 personnes et nous
7000 avait dépensé six millions d'euros
alors moi je sais pas comment ils font
je ne sais pas c'est vrai que tout ça
c'est terminé dans les prétoires mais je
ne sais pas comment ils font donc pour
répondre à votre question je pense que
la véritable injustice c'est pas une
question de finances dont vous avez pour
une élection présidentielle
l'essentiel de la campagne ça c'est dans
les médias à la radio à la télé par
ailleurs l'état paye pas remis même déjà
les affiches électorales les bulletins
de vote 45 millions de bulletins de vote
et la profession de foi donc ya pas
besoin d'avoir des sommes mirobolantes
ont souvent en revanche la véritable
injustice c'est l'accès aux médias parce
que quand vous pensez qu'une publicité
ou 22 vous savez à l'issue du 20 heures
de tf1
1 30 secondes ces dix hommes forme
fantastique je crois sa dizaine de
romans centaines de l'aude et oui je
crois c'est lucile 700000 euros pour
passer trente secondes vous imaginez
quelqu'un qui passe répète de façon
répétitive au 20 heures de tf1 vous avez
8 millions de téléspectateurs il
quelqu'un comme moi qui suis totalement
interdite d'antenne 2 contrairement à
toutes les règles d'ailleurs même les
règles qui fixe le csa le csa qui a été
complètement débranché on est face à
quelque chose d'absolument scandaleux
mais qui est connu dans toutes les
dictatures là nous avons une espèce de
démocratie de façade et monsieur macron
fait ce qu'il reproche à maduro le
président vénézuélien de fer ou abdou
thing en russie de faire c'est-à-dire
d'organiser l'invisibilité des vrais
opposants mais on est ici en tout cas
pour parler de votre programme et de vos
propositions alors il ya presque quinze
ans vous avez fondé lui perd sur trois
idées majeures quitter l'union
européenne quitter l'euro ait quitté
l'otan alors sur l'union européenne
d'abord le royaume uni a mis votre
souhait à exécution en activant
l'article 50 du traité de l'union
européenne qui permet un état de quitter
les lieux alors qu'avez vous retenu de
l'exemple britannique est ce qu'il vous
a confirmé dans votre conviction oui
tout à fait pourquoi parce que d'une
part enfin je veux dire sauf est d'une
mauvaise foi un signe les britanniques
ne sont pas un peuple d'extrême droite
donc ils ont prouvé qu'on peut vouloir
sortir de l'union européenne sans être
d'extrême droite sans être raciste
xénophobe antisémite conspirationniste
ce que j'ai pas entendu j'aurais un peu
je ferai d'ailleurs remarquer que le bus
le gouvernement britannique comporte des
ministres issus de ce qu'on appelle en
france la diversité par ailleurs madame
priti patel la ministre de l'intérieur
est d'origine indienne pakistanaise bon
et d'ailleurs elle et elle ferme
sévèrement l'immigration au royaume uni
on pourrait parler aussi du ministre des
finances donc ça c'est un premier acquis
la deuxième chose c'est que on vous
rappeler ce qu'on nous avait dit en
france et même pendant la présidentielle
de 2017 puisque le référendum sur le
break site a eu lieu en 2016 et ensuite
il ya eu des difficultés pendant
plusieurs années nesredine table de
négociations bon faudrait des deux
heures pour que j'explique à vos
visiteurs pourquoi mais au bout du
compte on nous avait expliqué que ce
sera l'apocalypse monsieur macron avait
dit qu'il accueillerait les réfugiés
économiques du royaume uni avec le tapis
rouge pourrait pousser à sortir toutes
les citations on avait dit qu'il y avait
des centaines de milliers de personnes
qui avaient traversé la manche
il ya non seulement n'y a rien eu de
tout ça mais la situation au royaume uni
même si les médias constamment essayé de
démolir boris johnson même encore
aujourd'hui en france on présente les
choses comme une affreux comme quelque
chose d'affreux et bien en réalité la
situation royaume-uni monde y est
meilleure qu'en france le taux de
chômage chez 4 5% nous on est à huit les
il ya eu perte aucun aucun pratiquement
personne n'a fui le royaume uni c'est le
contraire qui est vrai vous savez le
problème des les migrants veulent tous
aller au royaume uni les britanniques
pensaient qu'ils auraient 4 millions
d'européens qui demanderait un visa de
long séjour ceux qui vivaient depuis
longtemps royaume uni et que les autres
partir il ya eu 6 millions qui ont voulu
rester des grandes entreprises comme
google a créé son nouveau siège en
europe au royaume uni boeing a créé son
nouveau siège en europe au royaume uni
la borde la place de londres qui était
la place financière de londres et la
city et est redevenu la première place
financière au monde on pourrait ainsi
multiplier les exemples
sur le fait que le royaume-uni devenu
très attractif et puis il ya encore une
autre un autre à l'autre notre gbagbo
bat de la propagande qui disait qu'on
nous dit à nous si vous sortez de
l'union européenne vous voulez refermer
la france la france est beaucoup trop
petit ni la royaume-uni sortie de
l'union européenne il a fait quoi email
à renouer des liens avec tout ce qu'on
appelle le commonwealth ses anciennes
colonies il est redevenu une puissance
planétaire et il nous a mis la pâtée
excusez moi cette vulgarité d'expression
mais lors de la sphère des sous-marins
puisque je n'ai pas réalisé
c'est un triomphe diplomatique pour le
royaume-uni d'avoir avec les états unis
et l'australie éjecté la france du
marché des sous marins australiens voilà
c'est à dire qu'en réalité c'est nous
notre appartenance à l'union européenne
qui nourrit qu'ils ont nés dokuwiki
puisque on est soumis aux desiderata de
tous les pays de l'union européenne je
vais prendre deux exemples extrêmement
grave excusez moi mais moi j'aime bien
parler des sujets les plus importants un
mois je suis pas là pour parler pétain
et les juifs ou bien est ce qu'il faut
le pr noyelles et c'est ça ce sont des
diversions pour la population moi les
deux choses qui sont très très grave en
ce moment c'est ce qui se passe avec la
chine et ce qui se passe avec la russie
c'est à dire que les états unis
d'amérique et la l'union européenne qui
est le vassal idéologique géopolitique
des états unis d'amérique sont en train
de monter constamment la pression
peut-être pour aller jusqu'à un conflit
eh bien la france elle est embarquée
dans un soutien taïwan contre la chine
je rappelle que de gaulle avait
justement reconnu la chine populaire en
66 contre formose est ce si vous avez
donné une aura mondial extraordinaire on
est en train de saboter cet héritage de
de gaulle vers ce qui est quand même la
chine c'est quand même la première
puissance démographique économique
industrielle du monde maintenant on est
en train de partir en guerre contre ça
tout simplement parce que les états unis
sont sur son très inquiet de la montée
en puissance de l'aide de la chine et la
deuxième chose c'est la russie vis-à-vis
de la russie
ces jours ci voilà on vous envoie
maintenant voir parler de mon avis on a
des avions de chasse français qui à deux
reprises deux jours de sud ont été
interceptés par les russes mais qu'est
ce que font les chasseurs français dans
le cadre de l'otan en mer noire à
quelques kilomètres des frontières
russes qu'est ce qu'on dirait pas s'il y
avait des chasseurs russes qui arrivait
à quelques kilomètres du finistère de la
base de nos sous marins nucléaires
lanceurs d'engins à l'île longue donc on
a une posture agressive par notre
appartenance à l'union européenne et à
l'otan vous voulez me quitter l'union
européenne en activant l'article 52 des
femmes ayant les britanniques très bien
ça s'est très bien passé sitel heureux
s'est passé il ya eu des négociations
bon viril si je le dis avec une session
divisés mais on est tout le monde est
resté en bons termes avec le royaume uni
il n'y a pas eu de problèmes juridiques
parce que l'article 50 permet de sortir
de l'union européenne avec l'accord de
tous puisque c'est inscrit dans le
traité de l'estrie l'analyserait pour le
livre seul quitter l'euro ensuite alors
certain que vous avez rejoint sur la
question 2017 puis on fait marcher de
machine arrière quelles sont les raisons
pour lesquelles vous souhaitez changer
notre notre monnaie alors je voudrais et
un point que je répétais du le dira en
préambule c'est que si je propose la
sortie d' union européenne de l'euro et
de l'otan ce n'est pas par nostalgie
ringardisé xénophobie n'est ni nahla non
le programme que j'ai présentées qui est
disponible sur notre site huppert point
fr en en téléchargement c'est le premier
programme qui a été présentée par un
candidat il fait 63 pages tout le monde
peut aller le consulter il est très très
exhaustif et bien il ce que je veux
c'est rendre aux français leur
démocratie et faire ce qu'ils veulent
voir donc ils veulent entièrement il ya
un problème majeur de niveau de vie la
france est en train de s'appauvrir et
moi j'ai explique mais c'est un petit
peu compliqué il faut un petit pays
réfléchit j'explique que c'est notre
appartenance à l'euro donc à la même
monnaie que l'allemagne qui nous oblige
à des efforts de compétitivité constant
et nous n'avons encore rien vu par
rapport à ce qui arrive parce que madame
merkel était rare on dit c'est l'exemple
ce que olaf scholz n'est pas en train ou
ne va pas faire donc si je dis qu'il
faut sortir de l'euro c'est pas parce
que je suis un nostalgique du franc
c'est pas ça c'est tout simplement parce
que si on reste dans l'euro je ne veux
pas jouer les les prophètes de malheur
mais tout ce que je dis depuis 14 ans et
toujours vérifier et tous les gens qui
me connaissent professionnellement
savent que j'ai une qualité c'est que je
vois je vois j'ai de la prescience de la
prémonition je vois très bien ce qui va
arriver et bien je peux vous dire que si
nous restons dans l'euro là le peuple
français va s'appauvrir s'appauvrir
s'appauvrit toujours plus de même que
les peuples d'europe du sud parce que
nous ne pouvons pas structurellement
avoir la même monnaie que l'allemagne ou
les pays de tous les pays bas ou le
luxembourg c'est comme ça pour des
raisons de structures économiques de
traditions politiques et sociales et
syndicales etc etc si je propose donc
pour sortir de l'euro c'est parce que il
faut rétablir la france redonnez ou
prend aux français leur niveau de vie
permettra aux cylindrées d'une
relocalisation des entreprises parce que
notre monnaie est trop chère par rapport
à la compétitivité de l'économie
française un dernier mot sur cette
question je vois bien qu'il ya des gens
qui font peur aux français en disant
mais c'est trop de tares sais pas si on
va perdre 80 pas mais c'est faux tout ça
c c'est ce que les britanniques du de
bure excite avait appelé project faire
c'est de leur seul projet c'est de faire
peur aux gens c'est de terroriser non si
nous sortons de l'euro pour créer le
franc d'abord ce soit pas la première
fois dans l'histoire de france qu'on
créera le franc s'était créé la première
fois en 13 160 pour libérer jean le bon
c'est à dire le souverain
si nous sortons de l'euro et bien autres
monnaies se dépréciera sans doute de
l'ordre de 10 à 15% par rapport au
dollar mais nous aurons donc une baisse
des importations une flambée des
exportations donc ça a été estimée au
moins un million de chômeurs en moins et
puis nous nous prenons des garanties 12h
jeu d'hommes ici des garanties aux
français leurs emprunts et leurs dettes
seront convertis en francs comme ils
avaient été converties du franc à l'euro
en 2000 en 2002 personnes y avaient vu
malice bon bah nasa sera dans le sens
inverse
et ça n'aura aucun impact sur le montant
de leur dette c'est à dire c'est moi
parce que le franc perdra sur les
marchés extérieurs 10 ou 15% que leur
d'être augmentée ra de 10 à 15 points de
nom il remboursera ans en france ça
s'appelle la lex monnaies taille et les
retraites parce que parfois je vois des
adversaires politiques qui fait c'est de
faire peur aux retraités en disant que
si on fait ça terrible je dirais deux
choses la première c'est que nous je
prends la garantie d'indexer les
retraites sur le niveau de vie sur le
court 2 des prix de lindsay d'où qu'ils
ne perdront rien et puis gré une
deuxième chose aussi c'est du pur bon
sens philo je suis français mais que
dans quelques années je serai retraités
moi même donc je suis le premier
intéressé aussi à ce que les choses se
passent bien un faux pas je suis pas
quelqu'un qui se dit çà depuis dix mille
kilomètres alors quitté l'otan enfin
cette alliance militaire de l'atlantique
nord qui a été créé à la après la
deuxième guerre mondiale contre l'urss
aujourd'hui la situation n'est plus la
même que pendant la guerre froide même
si certains estiment que la russie
pourrait prochainement envahir l'ukraine
qui ne fait pas partie de l'otan on le
précise la russie est elle toujours une
menace selon alors écoutez d'abord
l'otan a été créée en 1949 et je vais
vous faire un petit à petit aveu c'est
que lorsque je suis entré à l'ena je
croyais j'avais jamais réfléchi que
c'était pour répondre à la menace
soviétique parce que j'avais été bercée
donc or quand vous prenez quand vous
regardez les il dit soit vous apercevez
que le pacte de varsovie a été écrit en
1953 donc c'est le pacte de varsovie est
écrit en réponse à l'otan et non inverse
de gaulle avait dit lorsque l'union
soviétique disparaîtra l'otan
disparaître là il s'était trompé pour le
coup parce qu'il avait sous-estimé le
fait que l'europe occidentale
l'union européenne en fait t'es
complètement assujettis mentalement
psychologiquement et c'est à
l'impérialisme des états unis moi ce que
je vois aujourd'hui si vous voulez on en
parlait tout à l'heure c'est me lasse
avec ses avions ce que je vois
aujourd'hui c'est que kim à ce défi
d'aider des armes du matériel militaire
sur la longue la frontière de qui est il
y à la france elle même a prépositionné
des engins blindés des avions dans une
base en estonie qui est à 200 km de
saint-pétersbourg tout le long de la
frontière russe en tout cas d'aidé de
l'union européenne
vous avez maintenant des quantités
d'engins blindés d'avions qui sont qui
menace en fait la russie là on nous dit
que la russie pourrait envahir d'ukraine
ce qui semble vrai je n'en sais rien
mais ce qui semble vrai c'est qu'il ya
effectivement et russes hamas des
troupes mais pourquoi parce que
qui a commencé si l'on peut dire les
états unis essaient de faire entrer
l'ukraine dans l'otan c'est-à-dire que
si l'ukraine entre dans l'otan la toute
l'ukraine sera alors à quelques
sentiers pas 1500 km de moscou de toutes
les blagues de la russie avec les armes
stratégiques les plus importantes donc
normalement dans ce genre de deux faits
on a affaire à des superpuissances bon
que diraient les états unis si la russie
ce matin des armements tout le long de
la frontière mexicaine est ce que vous
croyez qu'il serait content ça ferait un
scandale mondial j'imagine d'ailleurs
que l'union européenne et la france
dirais que c'est scandaleux et que c'est
une provocation à l'égard des états unis
donc normalement dans ce genre de
situation il faut que les gens aient la
sagesse de respecter ce que l'on appelle
un glacis de protection l'ukraine fait
partie de ceux glacis de protection et j
j'ai bien compris il ya une des
conversations de très haut niveau entre
baden et et poutine qui se connaissent
bien parce qu'ils se connaissent depuis
longtemps et si j'ai bien compris
poutine a dit que la ligne rouge à ne
pas franchir c'est faire entrer
l'ukraine dans l'otan c'est à dire qu
ils n'interviendront pas militairement
en ukraine mais si l'ukraine bascule
dans l'otan c'est-à-dire contrairement à
tous les engagements qu'ils avaient pris
de george bush le père vis-à-vis de
gorba de chauffe mende effondrement du
communisme là ça sera considéré par la
russie comme une déclaration de guerre
qu'est ce que l'on fait nous d'ailleurs
la france a envoyé des milliers d avion
le long de la frontière russe je le
demande ça coûte d'ailleurs des sommes
folles parce qu'une mission avec trois
avions ça coûte très très cher qu'est ce
qu'on fait là bas est ce que quelqu'un
peut m'expliquer plus tôt alors qu'on a
des problèmes à n'en plus finir en
france métropolitaine qu'est ce qu'on
fait dans ce genre de situation voilà
donc pour les trois points majeurs de
voir programme on va ensuite donc parler
de la démocratie dans votre programme
vous souhaitez rétablir je cite la
démocratie la plus large possible alors
pour cela vous souhaitez mettre en place
une réforme constitutionnelle soumise au
référendum alors une des premières
mesures c'est l'instauration du risque
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne
c'était l'une des revendications
principales du mouvement des gilets
jaunes lors quelles seront les
conditions de sa mise en place déjà je
ferai remarquer un point c'est que ceux
qui me connaissent depuis longtemps ou
tout simplement qui vont aller voir le
programme que j'avais présenté en 2010
verront que ça y était déjà ça s'appelle
ce que j'ai appelé ça le référendum
d'initiative populaire dont j'ai pris le
risque parce que c'est maintenant devenu
un acronyme plus connus mais ça veut
dire que je ne suis pas je suis pas
quelqu'un qui surf sur les événements je
refais je reformule que je reformule ce
que je formulais d'il ya déjà à cinq ans
alors sur ce rythme il faudra trouver
les modalités on ne peut pas avoir des
référendum tous les quatre matins c'est
non ce serait ingérable
donc il faut trouver des modalités qui
permettent d'organiser ça de façon
sereine comme le font les suisses avec
leur votation je crois que c'est une
période dans l'année ou deux périodes
dans l'année ou bien les californiens
c'est à dire que les californiens c'est
au moment des élections qui ont lieu
tous les deux ans vous savez pour la
chambre des représentants je crois que
c'est à ce moment là qu'il ya des
référendum d'initiative citoyenne et
bien il faut faire la même chose en
france il faudra prévoir qui est par
exemple une période dans l'année ou bien
une période je sais pas oui c'est ça
quelque chose comme ça il faudrait qu'il
ya aussi un minimum de signature de
dépôt de signature maintenant c'est très
facilité avec internet où les gens
pourront aller déposer dans des mairies
lors leurs signatures sur une pétition
vous savez qu'avec internet des systèmes
siltchenko org et où vous avez pouvait
recoller pour reccueillir j'ai passé un
sort mille sept cent mille signatures il
faut pas qu'on fasse des référendums sur
tous les sujets sinon ça serait le
blocage des institutions
d'autant que les gaulois sont quand même
des gaulois comme disait de gaulle c'est
le pays des 365 fromages tout le monde a
son avis sur tout ce qui est bien d'une
certaine façon ce qui est moins bien
c'est qu'ils sont devenus apathie qui
regarde il regarde apathie justement sur
france info dont qui sont là à réciter
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux à
réciter ce qu'ils entendent sur bfm tv
ou bien sur tf1 sans se documenter par
ailleurs donc voila moi je vous dis
faudrait que ça soit sans doute une
période de l'année avec un minimum de
signature et puis et ben je pense que
c'est sur tous les sujets j'ai pris un
dans mon programme donc sur une terre de
paix un point fr que les gens peuvent
aller voir et télécharger
j'ai pris un engagement que je suis je
suis certain que je suis le seul
candidat à prendre cet engagement c'est
que je propose 27 sujet très important
où je peux vous fait des rouges et des
propositions très précises et très
concrètes notamment l'augmentation du
niveau de vie très importante là
également l'oncle la gamme s'occuper de
la sécurité qui préoccupe tant les
français à la fois en redonnant des
vrais dotations budgétaires à la police
à la gendarmerie et à la justice mais
aussi en ayant une société qui arrêtent
de créer des disparités sociales trop
importante parce que si vous voulez
actuellement il ya de plus en plus de
pauvres épines des quelques quelques
centaines de personnes le plus en plus
riches sacré sacré toutes les conditions
d'une explosion sociale et d'une montée
de l'insécurité donc tout ça je paie
toutes ces propositions est la dernière
des propositions que je fais et je pense
je suis le seul candidat le faire c'est
que je dis que si à mi chemin au bout de
deux ans et demi de mandat je n'ai pas
mis en oeuvre la moitié de ces
propositions est bien j'organiserai un
référendum pour demander aux français
s'ils veulent c'est que stop ou encore
est-ce que je continue mon mandat ou
est-ce qu'il ne révoque voilà et je
pense que c'est très important et
pourquoi je fais cette proposition
pourquoi je me permets de la faire parce
que je suis certain de pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre mes propositions justement parce
que je m'en donne les moyens juridiques
en sortant de l'union européenne de
l'eau et de l'otan tous les autres
candidats de madame le pen à monsieur
mélenchon en passant par zemmour en
passant par madame pécresse en passant
par jadot etc font des quantités de
promesses donc les français ils voient
que les promesses ne sont pas tenues et
donc il ya beaucoup de français qui
abandonnent et qui se dit moi je tous
les politiques je veux plus en parler
mais pourquoi moi j'explique depuis 14
ans qu'ils ne peuvent pas tenir leurs
promesses parce qu'une fois que les
flonflons de la campagne électorale se
sont éteints et bien à ce moment là il
découvre la réalité la réalité qui les
trouvent ils sont obligés d'adopter
d'accepter les directives venues de
bruxelles ou venue de francfort ou de
washington c'est ça et c'est pour ça que
les autres candidats ne peuvent pas
prendre l'engagement que je prends moi
de ce référendum révocatoire au bout de
6 de deux ans et six mois merci beaucoup
françois asselineau mayrand était avec
nous dans l'hebdo politique je rappelle
que vous êtes le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de l'upm et moi je vous
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau nul au de l'hebdo
politique très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
l'hebdo politique